since Avengers in game has officially
been released on digital we have been
getting a ton of information about the
movie and a ton of confirmation from the
directors and the writers and a lot of
information that we've gotten recently
has been about Captain America how's it
goin everybody it's Warren and Captain
America going back in time at the end of
Avengers endgame and deciding to stay in
the past sure has raised a whole bunch
of questions in regards to his timeline
in the movie it seemed pretty clear that
if you go back in time and change any of
the events that happened you would
create an alternate timeline and that
alternate timeline would have no effect
on the current main timeline
however the writers of Avengers in game
have recently revealed that they kind of
made up their own rules and stated that
you only create an alternate timeline if
you take one of the Infinity stones away
therefore Captain America going back in
time and returning the Infinity stones
to the exact point in which they were
taken prevented alternate timelines from
happening and the Hulk even confirms
this right before Captain America goes
back in time he says make sure you
return all of the Infinity stones at the
exact point in which they were taken or
you're going to open up a bunch of nasty
alternate timelines so Captain America
went back in time and returned all of
the Infinity stones right after they
were taken in different timelines
therefore he created no alternate
timelines so when he went back in time
and stayed back in time with Peggy
Carter that was still the main universe
in which he was from in fact the writers
went on to confirm that old man Steve
Rogers was in fact at Peggy Carter's
funeral in Captain America Civil War now
this is what the writers Christopher
Marcus and Stephen McFeely say and the
writers and the directors the Russo
brothers don't exactly agree on this
Captain America timeline the Russo
brothers think that there could be an
alternate timeline in which Captain
America lived out his life however they
did comment something recently in ask me
anything that further backs up the point
that Captain America exists in the same
timeline and did not create an alternate
timeline they were asked that if Captain
America was in an alternate timeline how
did he get back to the present at the
end of Avengers endgame and the rooster
brother said he would have had to have
worn the quantum suit using a Pym
particle to make the jump he's not
wearing the suit on the bench because
that is not the exact moment to which he
returned so the researchers just said
that this is not the exact point in
which Captain America returned to this
timeline therefore the argument
he made that he was a part of that
timeline the whole entire time because
when he went back in time it didn't
create an alternate timeline it seems
like the Russo brothers are still
sticking to the alternate timeline
Captain America story and although they
are the directors Christopher Marcus and
Stephen McFeely wrote Captain America
the Winter Soldier Captain America Civil
War and Avengers infinity war and
Avengers endgame and they have confirmed
that in Captain America the Winter
Soldier when Peggy is talking about her
husband and kids she is actually talking
about Steve confirming that Steve was
her husband the whole entire time
because he went back in time and stayed
with her and now the Russo brothers have
said that at the end of Avengers in game
when Captain America is sitting on the
bench this is not a point in which she
returned he had been in that timeline
previously so that does seem to line up
with what Christopher Marcus and Stephen
McFeely said he went back in time and
stayed in the same current timeline and
at the end of Avengers endgame he just
knew where to be and he was already in
the current timeline so tell me what you
think about this would you rather have
Captain America going back in time and
staying with Peggy Carr to create an
alternate timeline or would you rather
have Captain America going back in time
and staying with Peggy Carter exist in
the same current timeline making him the
husband of Peggy Carter and the father
of her children the whole entire time
let me know what you think in the
comments down below and also don't
forget to comment with your favorite
superhero or villain like this video and
subscribe to my channel so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 I'll be picking a winner at
500,000 subscribers and I'm also still
giving away some Marvel Legends items as
well don't forget to follow me on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof